SPECIFICALLY OVER THE EASTERN
PART OF THE CITY AND THERE IS A
LOST SMOKE THERE.
>> Sean: MIKE, JOINING US IN
REACTION TO AT THIS TIME NEWS.
SEBASTIAN GOSHOV AND FORMER
LIEUTENANT AND OFFICER TONY
SCHAFER.
DOCTOR, I BEGIN WITH YOU.
SOMETIMES THE COUNTRIES ACT AND
IT IS IT THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
THE WORLD SEES HORRIFIC IMAGES
OF INNOCENT PEOPLE.
THE ONGOING CIVIL WAR HERE THAT
IS GOING ON.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS SENDING
A CLEAR MESSAGE.
THE EVIL ATTACK THAT LED MOTHERS
FATHERS AND INFANT AND CHILDREN
GASPING FOR AIR.
THEY ARE NOT ACTIONS OF A MAN
BUT OF A MONSTER.
THE CHALLENGE TO RUSSIA AND IRAN
DIRECTLY, YOUR REACTION?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT AN
INTERVENTIONIST AND I KNOW THE
LEFT DOESN'T BELIEVE THIS.
HE IS A VERY, VERY COMPASSIONATE
MAN.
WHETHER HE'S MEETING WITH
VICTIMS FROM PARKLAND OR LOOKING
AT THE FOOTAGE OF THAT CHEMICAL
WEAPON'S ATTACK IN SYRIA.
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN A LARGE
FOOT PRINT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES IN.
BUT HE BELIEVES IN FOR EVIL TO
TRIUMPH, ALL YOU NEED IS FOR
GOOD MEN TO DO NOTHING.
WE ARE STANDING UP FOR THE
MORALITUDE OF THE NATION.
WE CAN'T FIX EVERYTHING.
THERE ARE EVIL AROUND THE WORLD
AND WE CAN'T SOLVE ALL OF THEM.
BUT WHEN WE HAVE A CAPACITY TO
RESPOND TO A MONSTER LIKE ASSAD
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR A CIVIL
WAR THAT HAS CAUSED THE DEATHS
IN SEVEN YEARS OF HALF MILLION
PEOPLE.
IF WE HAVE A CAPACITY TO RESPOND
WE ARE DUTY- BOUND TO DO SO.
HE SENT A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE TO
RUSSIA AND IRAN, YOU HAVE TO
DRAW YOUR OWN INTERNAL REDLINES
NOW.
AND YOU HAVE TO DECIDE IF YOU
ARE PREPARED TO PAY A FURTHER
PRICE FOR SPONSORING A REGIME AS
EVIL AS BASHAR ALASSAD.
SFSHGS AND THEN HE HELD OUT THE
ADVANTAGES OF BEING FRIENDS TO
THE UNITED STATES.
ECONOMIC AND AS HIGH OFTEN DOES.
THE WORDS OF THE PRESIDENT
FOLLOWING THE HORRORS OF WORLD
WAR I, A CENTURY AGO.
CIVILIZED NATIONS JOINED
TOGETHER TO BAN CHEMICAL WARFARE
AND THEY ARE UNIQUELY DANGEROUS
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF GRUESOME
SUFFERING, BUT SMALL AMOUNTS CAN
UNLEASH WIDESPREAD DEVASTATION
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE ACTION TO
ESTABLISH A STRONG DETERRENT AND
USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPON AND HE
WENT ON ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
SPECIFIC PRECISION STRIKES.
IT IS NOT A LONG-TERM PROTRACTED
CONFLICT, IT IS IT TO STOP THE
SPECIFIC USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS
AS WE SAW THE IMAGES THIS WEEK.
>> YES, SEAN, ABSOLUTELY.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT ON THE
MONEY IN TALKING ABOUT THE
DEVASTATION THAT CHEMICAL
WEAPONS CAN CAUSE AND YOU KNOW,
IT IS PART OF OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGY.
THERE ARE TWO UNDERLYING
PRINCIPLES.
ONE TO STOP THE PROLIFERATION OF
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION AND
INCLUDING CHEMICAL AND
BIOLOGICAL AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AND THE RULE OF LAW.
THE PRESIDENT IS SIMPLY
IMPLEMENTING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGY AND I DON'T
REMEMBER IN RECENT HISTORY OR
EVER IN HISTORIAN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS SO GOOD AT SYNCHRONIZING
THE ELEMENTS OF POWER WHEN THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONED DIPLOMATIC
AND MILITARY AND ECONOMIC.
AND I WOULD ADD IN THERE
INFORMATION.
HIS TWEETS AND THE WAY THAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION SHAPES
INFORMATION AND TARGETS.
HEAP LAID OUT IN ONE OF HIS
TWEETS AN ECONOMIC OLIVE BRANCH
TO RUSSIA TO TRY TO PULL THEM
AND HE HAS A TWEET THAT SENDS
THE RUSSIAN NAVY IN TO THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
THAT IS POWERFUL AND THAT IS AN
ELEMENT OF NATIONAL POWER AND
DIPLOMATICALLY, WE SUBMITTED
A U.N. RESOLUTION AND RUSSIA
VETOED IT AS THEY DID 12 OTHER
TIMES IN REGARD TO PROTECTING
SYRIA AND THE MURDEROUS REGIME.
AND SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
DIPLOMACY AND MILITARY AND
ECONOMIC.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS IT RIGHT
ON ISIS AND NORTH KOREA AND
GETTING IT RIGHT HERE IN MY
OPINION.
WHAT WE HAVE TONIGHT IS BRAVE
SOULS OUT THERE FLYING AIR COVER
AND CRUISE MISSILES GOING IN AND
I WOULD BETTER MONEY THEY ARE
TARGETING THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE RUSSIAN SPENT
AND SHOOT DOWN THE U.S.
AIRPLANES AND WE CAN DO BATTLE
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT WHEN THE SUN
COMES UP AND THEN THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER WAVE.
WE ARE COMING IN WITH CRUISE
MISSILES.
WE HAVE B- TWO BOMBERS AND
OTHERS TYPES OF AIRCRAFT READY
TO ATTACK TARGETS IN SYRIA.
>> Sean: I WOULD TO GO BACK TO
THE DOCTOR GORKA.
THESE ARE PRESIPGZ STRIKES
A COALITION.
WILLING INCLUDING FRANCE AND
GREAT BRITAIN.
WHAT KIND OF NATION WANTS TO BE
ASSOCIATED.
A DIRECT APPEAL TO RUSSIA AND
TEHERAN TONIGHT.
WHAT NATION WANTS TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH MASS MURDER OF
MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
AND NATIONS CAN BE JUDGED BY THE
FRIENDS THEY KEEP.
AND NO NATION CAN SUCCEED WITH
PROMOTING MURDERING ROGUE DESPOT
DICTATORS.
REMEMBER IT WAS OBAMA DREW THE
REDLINE IN THE SAND AND JOHN
KERRY SAID 100 PERCENT OF THE
WEAPONS ARE GONE.
THEY'RE NOT.
>> THEY ARE NOT.
AND IT WAS RUSSIA THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO GUARANTEE THE
WITHDRAW ALL OF THAT WEAPONS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVED THEM.
AND THE BRIGGADERSAID IT
CORRECTLY.
IT IS NOT JUST HORRIBLE PICTURE
AND EMOTIONAL RESPONSE.
THIS IS ILLEGAL BY ALL STANDARDS
OF HUMANITY AND INTERNATIONAL
LAW.
YOU CAN GO TO WAR AND DEFEND
YOUR NATION'S INTERNATIONAL
INTEREST BUT YOU CAN'T USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AND THEY ARE
USED AGAINST WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
AND WHAT DOES IT SAY TO ALL OF
THE FOX VIEWERS WHO MAY BE
WORRIED.
ONE QUESTION FOR YOU.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT AMERICA
IF WE DO NOTHING AFTER SUCH AN
EVENT?
WHERE A MONSTER USES THESE TYPES
OF WEAPONS AGAINST CHILDREN?
AMERICA MUST RESPOND.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE VERY
PRECISE, SURGICAL AND TOMAHAWK
CAPABILITY AND ALSO SYMBOLIC
TARGETS THAT SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO ASSAD.
WE HAVE SAVED WESTERN
CIVILIZATION ALREADY MANY TIMES
IN THE 20th CENTURY.
WHETHER IT IS IT NAZIS AND
FACIST OR WINNING THE COLD WAR
OR ISIS AND TAKING DOWN THE